it is good to see you and honey you
cleaned up well tonight that is for sure
thank you it's good to see you too how
you been i've been doing great and i
think you're doing pretty darn well
tonight too mr new
artist dma award winner that's nice it
feels nice to hear that it's a good
night for sure that is so
awesome morgan and then your performance
my hometown
you are in this venue that is larger
than life but then you have this
intimate
audience in front of you and some of the
biggest names in country music
was that a little bit intimidating yeah
it is to
to an extent you know especially when
you know people like eric church who's
my favorite country music singer ever is
in the crowd
which i've kind of got to know him a
little bit over the past few months so
that kind of made that
that a little bit easier but yeah it's
there's definitely it's a little bit
more nerve-wracking than going to play
and you don't know
jacksonville or somewhere you know it's
a little bit that's not it's not a
bad thing about jacksonville i love
jacksonville y'all of course you do
it's like a handful of people in the
audience and it's like hey carrie
underwood hey miranda lambert
hey aaron morris luke comes it's insane
now i gotta ask you buddy
we uh you know unfortunately you weren't
able to perform on snl
due to coved and you breaking protocol
so what have you learned from that
experience because you had
a very emotional apology and
announcement that you made
on instagram but what have you learned
from that incident
yeah i mean i think i just gotta be
aware that most of my actions will you
know
if especially if i'm in a public
situation it's going to be brought to
light
and before all that kind of happened i
didn't i didn't i don't think i really
truly understand the
the reach that i have um it's kind of
just all hit me over
over quarantine a little bit you know i
feel like things have really
ramped up throughout this whole thing
and i don't know this this year has been
kind of just jacked up anyway and i just
haven't handled it the best way and at
all but
um if you don't want people to to see
those kind of things
i guess do it in private yeah exactly
maybe not on the tick tock honey okay
okay i got you not on the tick tock but
i got to say a lot of your fans and you
have so many of them are talking about
your latest music video
and you are dropping some easter eggs
perhaps in your music video
for your upcoming album you've got some
jerseys in there lined up with
one 8 21 so is that the date of your new
album yeah it is january 2021 i'm
i'm working on well it's actually done
i've already turned it in it's a double
album
i'm actually going to announce the track
list and everything after the awards
tonight
um it's going to be 32 songs once it's
all said and done
32 yeah i haven't just been getting on
tick tock during during quarantine i've
been working too all right we've worked
really really really hard on it and it's
uh
i'm really proud of it so i can't wait
till then that is awesome because i've
seen so many of your live performances
on instagram and you just have an
incredible voice what we hear
on your albums on the radio is what we
get on the gram
and what we get in a live performance
like we got tonight with the cma awards
of course we find ourselves anticipating
and getting ready for the holiday season
how are you going to be spending the
holidays with your new little guy
yeah yeah we me and his mother are going
to work that out to where she gets him
and i get them and
i'm going to take him to see my folks
obviously i'm spending most of my time
in the holidays back in east tennessee